I'm gonna be the next Lara Croft if at
least she doesn't come back so we saw
how ripped olesja got for this film
right yeah yeah I saw it on a daily
basis yeah I saw her work out almost
well every other day because she was
there every day I was just a freak but
yeah it was it was pretty extraordinary
and one time I got to the gym at like
7:00 in the morning and that walked in
and she was there with Magnus her
trainer who's an unbelievable guy and a
real kind did you really okay to my bus
yeah that's exactly right and and I said
because I wanted to beat her one morning
yeah what did be there I wanted to be
pumping some weight or pushing weight
when she walked in and instead she is
had already been there for a couple of
hours you know and it's like well okay
never gonna win this because I'm not
getting up before 6 o'clock in the
morning less that's my call time so
never get it never happened I like to
know that you're being very honest about
the fact that you felt a little need to
yeah yeah that's right yeah and I mean
and I you know we both Dominic West and
I benefit benefited from the fact that
Alicia had her own chef there because of
her regime I mean indeed that she needed
to look this way and in order to look
this way she had to eat a certain way
and and I think they just felt really
sorry for Dominick they just gave us her
extra salmon yeah her extra fish and and
and they made it look like it was it was
so pitiful as if they they had hired it
for they had hired this incredible chef
for all three of us you know and I said
oh you didn't this is the fish that she
didn't eat this is what I'm eating right
now what are you saying and all of those
lentils and that Beluga we are wheat or
whatever that is yeah
there you go by proxy you gotta find you
got in great shape I did yeah yeah yeah
and you wouldn't know it you know but
but you know I'm alright I'm gonna be
the next Lara Croft police you doesn't
come back
besides our dedication to the work out
and that you know the physicality of it
all what makes so perfect to be this new
tomb raider or to be the first I guess
you know I mean to say this is not to
say that Angelina is an actor's actor
you know but um but Alicia in 2018 is an
actor's actor yeah and and in her
interpretation of almost anything that
she does is is grounded in truth the way
she listens is grounded in truth when
she speaks it's grounded in truth and
and I and I think that's what the world
needs right now you know really and and
I think she is she's the perfect person
to evolve this story and to bridge it
from where Angelina
start a bit to maybe in another 20 years
from now wherever it goes from here you
know I I don't know the answer to that
question but um but it was really
something just to see her take on a
genre that she is not only not known for
she's never done and and to do it with
the same focus and tenacity that she
approaches the other things in her life
now I'm gonna say this so fix it in your
head cuz it's gonna sound a little
bittersweet Vicks on okay for me in this
type of genre a lady really has to make
me believe she can fight somebody and
kick some butt that girl made me bully I
was like she is fighting yeah and of it
yeah I think I think that's a I think
that's a wise and very smart criticism
coming to an experience like this and
say okay that's gonna be my my my
barometer that's my watermark right
either you have it or you
don't have it and and you know we she
went to great lengths to make those
plausible and we with war and with
Graham King our producer went to great
lengths to make those physical kind of
interactions between these characters be
about not just about physical
capabilities to which Alicia and her
interpretation of Lara Croft AB but also
just about her over her wits you know
and her mind and and and and and I think
I think we we did that I think it's
really believable is your character evil
or has he just gone mad from the
frustration of all those years of not
being able to yeah I don't God you know
evil no I don't I don't think he's I
don't think he's evil isn't it I think
you know I've certainly been a location
for a very long time and I have had
those down days where I desperately
wanted to see my little boy mm-hmm I and
my wife and and and it gets dark you
know it gets really really dark and and
here this man is vocalist has been away
from his family looking for something
that he's incapable of finding right day
in and day out doing the same thing and
I and I and I think he's just tired and
when it happens when she lands there and
she gives him the information that he's
been looking for I think that he's
thinking about one thing and one thing
his hugging his children you know and
who can't understand that look at you
making him pathetic I love it working
around this world war this palm soon can
I tell you how much I love your bromance
with Sam Rockwell that's my homeboy I
love that it's my buddy yeah yeah yeah I
well you know what I love it too
and then I hope that you put this in
your segment because I think I think Sam
Rockwell is the best in our in our
generation I mean Sam and I are close in
age he's a little bit older but but he
is a you know he's like he's like Robert
Duvall is to me you know and and I
admired him from afar for a very long
time and and we had friends in common
but then we did a movie together Cowboys
and Aliens and we became thick as
thieves yeah he's my he's my I talked to
him this morning
he's good he's on role he's doing it
right I mean he's doing it I'm not
superstitious so you know I already
think he's got that he's already won I
mean he's already like like across the
board even without any of this but but
but this is a man who's been on this
journey for 20 years 25 years and and
and everyone has wanted this for him for
as far back as we can remember and now
it's it's it's his time and and I think
that everybody feels really good about
it are you gonna have a viewing party
are you gonna try to go you know I'm
gonna see what my what my man is what
he's up to
you know yeah we got a couple things and
works you know and there's there's a
there's a you know a crew of people that
that are very close to Sam and that are
also very close to me and um and and
it's one of Nate nurturing and and and
friendship I love that yeah you're
joining the Marvel Universe it ant-man
and the wasps and Menelaus yeah it's
pretty cool it's pretty cool I gotta
tell you I mean I have I have three god
children who also happen to be two
nephews and a niece
and Quentin Tarantino for them is like
you know look I was nine when that
happened so it's not that big of a deal
now they're like 11 and I Tomb Raider
you an ant-man
hey what's you you want to hang out with
me gonna hang out with my friends hey
would you would you build my Instagram
so that's uh that's that's that's pretty
cool how was y'all's trip to Black
Panther I saw I took one of my mind my
godson and and it was God it was so
culturally significant and everybody
knew it and felt it in that room but
then us like once you kind of get just
you get to go through that door just the
movie is so good
it's and everybody is so good in it yeah
I just loved it
I've seen it twice have you really yeah
yeah yeah yeah you are taking over Kevin
Spacey's role in LA Confidential right
yeah so what about because it's iconic
you know right oh do I know that Noah
have they did they ever do a movie about
Le Conte I don't know we're talking
about you don't just ask the question
the question is why did you do this why
would anyone ever but seriously I mean
that's like I mean are you nervous are
you ready are you you know yeah I'm
nervous yeah I'm terrified you know
really and I think I think we all are
but I also think that um that the the
director is a very good friend of mine
Michael dinner and it's somebody that I
trust that I went on a six-year journey
with or justified and and I had a long
conversation with this writer Jordan and
and Anna his partner and and what they
want to do and how they want to tell
this story is not a remake of the movie
you know it is uh it is mr. Elroy's
novel and and and I
you know I think there's a real place
for it and and I live in Los Angeles and
and I love my city and and I think that
you can only love it more when you put a
critical eye on it you know and and so
I'm excited about it and then if we
succeed we succeed and if we fail we
fail I mean to not take those
opportunities of those chances whoo-hoo
suffering really yeah I would be listen
I'm here for it yeah obviously we'll see
what I am a lover yeah me too we take
you know what and and it's been you know
it's been what 20 years all right so I
can tell you that I will not be seeing
that movie no no way I don't want any I
don't want any part of another listening
soundtrack I'm not even looking at at
her cape you know a Kim's cape I don't
want nothing I know image